hello friends I'm Lana and welcome to my
channel today I'm doing a subscribe
today I'm doing another Q&A for hitting
310 and 315 thousand subscribers thank
you guys also I'm bad at this so I've
decided to change it I'm now going to be
doing Q&A is just the first Friday of
every month the process of like hitting
the thing and then taking the questions
and then uploading it getting it up in
time never works so we're just gonna do
one a month you know you can leave your
questions in the comments below rather
than me having to source them from
Instagram and Twitter and stuff but
still thank you for subscribing I'm
gonna find a different way to thank you
to the questions has anyone ever told
you you look a lot like Emma Roberts all
the time and I hate it because I see it
but what I see in her is the stuff that
I don't like about my own face so Bhama
sorry the question was from James Spears
Jose Rodriguez asks what's the longest
you go without playing video probably
watch a video very day or so I think
pretty frequently I love a good mp4 it's
one of my favorite file formats if I'm
being honest I assume in videogames and
honestly the longest I go is a day or
two I get like stuck raisi if I don't
play video games for a while won't link
us what random video game did you buy
knowing nothing about it and enjoyed it
docksiders was that for me I bought
dockside is one because the couple was
shiny that's it
taco one 3:37 said do Aussies really say
the c-word all the time he did write it
out but I don't want to get D monetized
so I have a few Aussie friends and
that's all they say so I was wondering
if all Aussies do it definitely not all
Australians it is not a word that is
said in my family really at all but
important note is that no matter what it
is no where near as offensive as it is
in the US ninja pork chop said what was
it like moving from Australia to America
I feel like I get questions like this
all the time so I try not to answer them
like every video because that would be
like most of what my video my Q&A videos
end up being about what was it like
moving from Australia to America I had a
long time plan I always planned to do it
and it was extremely difficult getting a
visa is very hard and very expensive
requires about six months worth of a
part-time jobs worth of paperwork
and then they just kind of prove you one
day and you can move or they don't and
they take all the money that you spent
which is like around ten thousand
dollars and then you know once you have
the visa you can get kicked out at any
time they can just revoke it so I I
think about my visa status on a daily
basis it is consistently stressful I
have to renew my visa every three years
or annually it varies this shit's
complicated and every time there's a
chance that they could decline it and I
would lose my job and just have to pack
it up and go back to Australia it's nuts
man
it was very exciting but it's also very
weird you know I kind of often think
about the fact that I moved away from
literally everyone I had ever known
every friend I had ever had my whole
family it was hard but yeah equal parts
exciting Xion Todd said hey Lana I know
you guys have known about it for a lot
longer than the rest of us but I wanted
to know how y'all handling the loss of
Lawrence at funhaus Lawrence had kind of
already transitioned over to inside
gaming in January last year so I was
doing a lot less fun house content in
any case so the transition from him to
doing that to leaving wasn't as abrupt
for us as it was for the inside gaming
team of course they were losing that
boss so for me it sucks because I love
Lawrence to bits
I have plans to continue making stuff
with him in any case just for fun and I
do want to address I saw some theories
like people think that it's my fault
that Lawrence left because I stole GTA
and Google Trends from him I always want
to say Google Trends was a show that I
explicitly did not want to do I I was
like I will do this because you know you
got to do your job if your boss tells
you to do something and you do it but I
really did not want to do that show I
didn't want to be the host of that at
all because I thought people would be
very unhappy with me taking it over from
Lawrence very different people I don't
have the energy Lawrence does I know
that I thought people would be mad and I
said that like repeatedly like I don't
want to do this I don't want to do this
but I'll do it but I do not want to so
that that was something that I didn't
ask for I didn't ask for GTA either
actually GTA like I was less against but
was also not something I ever asked to
do they were both given to me because
Lawrence seen a more time
KJ look and said you've said before that
you don't date why is that
okay bye don't date I the only way that
I will ever really get into a
relationship with someone is if I have
met them organically somehow we have
already been talking for a fair amount
of time I've gotten to know them and
then we go on a date I will never use a
first date as a way to get to know
someone because you couldn't ask me on a
date
unless I'm already comfortable enough
that I know you I think every date bar
the one on this channel that it's my
worst date story ever that I've been on
it did end up being someone I was in a
relationship with I don't do like dating
I don't do dating apps I don't do like
dating around enjoying the single life
meeting people type [ __ ] I just meet
someone on ganna click through a friend
or whatever like them talk to them a lot
start dating that makes sense I think
because of the way that I do that I
never have anniversaries in my
relationships my current relationship
does not have an anniversary my last
relationship didn't have an anniversary
we were just like kind of dating one day
weird the Alpha Reich said the Google
Trends with you and Blaine was so
amazingly awkward and it seemed like you
weren't really happy with the situation
so why did the two of you agree to that
it is crazy how many comments we got
like this so for the record Google
Trends I choose everyone who's on it I
found out Blaine was gonna be in town I
invited him it wasn't and agreed to it
kind of situation and I was very happy
with the situation of all of the people
who were in that room which i think was
like James Elise Chris Blaine I'm the
closest to blame like by a mile we dated
for three years and I'm playing into
that because I know it's entertaining
like I try to bring up ex-girlfriend
stuff with him pretty often I make those
jokes on Twitter and people like thought
that it was beef but it's really just us
being playful about the fact that we
dated and aunt anymore it just seemed
like so much of humans being very
uncomfortable seeing two exes and like
projecting I think a little maybe I
don't really know but it's definitely
incorrect melancholic 47
question we you a high achiever during
your school days or in university yes
but very subject specific I got a lot of
azor like high B's in high school pretty
consistently but that's because I got
out of doing science and maths Josh Oh
said when was the last time a game made
you feel guilty definitely animal
crossing every time I would shut that
thing off without saving a new leaf that
got me bad Nick Vitaly said what to take
on Sakura know having easier difficulty
settings I have limited time for gaming
these days so can't put in the hours it
takes to master super difficult but
would love to experience this game I'm
one of it split on this and that when
you say you would love to experience
this game what you're experiencing in
Sakura is difficult combat that's part
of the experience of that game so if you
want to easy a difficulty I would argue
that you don't really want to experience
Sakura that said Sakura's exploration
and unique approach to buses and all
that stuff is also very cool and worth
seeing even if you want like struggling
through the combat because it is hard
look I think I land on the side of I
feel like every game should have as many
options as possible because then it's
more accessible and more people can play
it I think that is generally how I feel
make gaming for everyone as accessible
as possible without limiting the appeal
of things being more challenging for the
people who are up to the challenge or
once the challenge is just a blanket
statement but I'm conflicted like I find
it a difficult thing to answer Corey
Maki said have you ever had a threesome
yeah your mom and your dad get [ __ ]
Corey SP McCallister said hey Alana just
curious what are your favorite books on
trilogies that you've loved and all
returned to periodically to read again
there are a lot of ways in which I think
I'm weird and one of them is that I will
not read a book series twice why would I
do that when I could read other things
it's like people who go to Disneyland
five times a year why don't you go
anywhere else new experience is a super
cool another way I think I'm very weird
is that I don't care about sequels
Deadly Premonition is my favorite game
Deadly Premonition - got announced
Terran cap
like Ilana you must be very excited it
was like why would I like cool but like
the first one is my favorite game I
didn't need more I loved it why do I
need more - yeah I don't I don't know
that's just what my brain works
I don't want sequels a lot of the time
if things are great I'm like it was
great something new favorite books I
love the night angel trilogy
I love the miss Bourne series I love the
Eragon series what is it the inheritance
cycle um yeah right now I'm still
reading through Wheel of Time it's taken
a long time
we're in Beck what's your love life
looking like and where do I put my
application Congrats on 300k oh thank
you my love life is excellent I'm very
happy and taken and happy about it it's
great be weird if you submitted an
application
it's a monogamous relationship there are
two of us I don't know that there's
really room for a third so I'm not
really sure what role you can apply for
but thank you for your interest I
appreciate it
kill a monkey five four six five seven
just curious why you want to meet &
Greets anymore don't mean to get up in
your business just wonder if we did
anything wrong it's just a security
issue but I'm still very much okay with
if anyone wants to come up to me and say
hi 100% do that in Amiens question for
the next Q&A why do you delete so many
of your tweets and Instagram posts this
is like a minor OCD and I don't want to
like talk about this in a way that's
like oh my god I have obsessive disorder
I am so troubled because this is like so
extremely minor that like I'm aware that
there are people who suffer with that
and it inhibits them on a day-to-day
basis no I just it's like a it's a it's
an OCD in which if I have the digital
feed it happens for folders as well that
looks messy like like if - Instagram
post is sitting on my page one above
each other and then - similar in color
I'll end up removing one of them [ __ ]
that nobody cares about like no one else
is going to look at that and be like
those pictures are too similar and
they're adjacent it's just a weird like
I get like this scratch with digital
organizations specifically
and that's pretty much it everyone yeah
otherwise for those of you is still here
at the end which I know is probably a
bad time to announce this because it
won't be that many of you I for the
first time ever I'm dropping much today
I'll leave a link in the description
below but basically it is 100% of
proceeds from me are going to charity
why is specifically which is a wildlife
charity in Australia and it's limited
time so this will only be available for
about a month I think I'd love for you
guys to join me in helping out to raise
money because the wildlife definitely
still needs help there are still things
on fire it has not gone away so yeah
check the link in the description and
that's it I'm alone I'll see you guys
next time bye